hey everybody dance I ever hear filling
in for ryan right because I'm wearing my
pants today improvement today I'm gonna
be watching The Devil's third trailer
which out of all of the we stuff that I
took a look at during e3 the devil's
third was actually one that I didn't
really see well almost anything about so
as far as like what this game is about
and everything it's like I I don't know
but I'm really excited I only heard like
this game is definitely something to pay
attention to to check out so I'm gonna
watch a trailer I'm just gonna go ahead
and eat that button my my double booth
day yeah then I'll put that [ __ ] full
screen then why hate play Oh [ __ ]
awesome that cat no look could get a job
this is something that can be said oh
okay all right
oh my god
I want this so bad to be the Duke Nukem
of 2014
Jane hello Ivan it's been here Oh
combining a ton of elements here in
October hearing
what used to come over why do you blind
yourself
drums I'm actually really interested um
and this is one of the things that I
always enjoy from like Nintendo games
and this sort of stuff is that they're
different in like something that you
just normally don't see on you know xbox
or playstation and this is just like
another example and it's cool because it
looks like it's mixed mixing like the
ninja gaiden and devil may cry series
with a little bit of that battlefield
call of duty first person shooter aspect
together I wonder how it's gonna play
out as far as controls are concerned
because I know at least when I was
playing the most recent double may cry
you know I i'm using all of the buttons
i don't i didn't feel like there was a
one button that i didn't really use so
it'll be interesting to see how you
switch between you know like using
whatever weapon you have I mean if is it
like you just swap between sword and gun
I do just kind of way to make a quick
note that you know the Wii is not the
wii u is not as powerful the system so
you can kind of tell that like some of
the graphic capabilities don't really
like in on par with you know that of the
ps4 or the xbox one but honestly from me
you know the graphics don't really
matter is if the gameplay really pushes
through I mean if the graphics become
kind of like a distracting issue from
the game okay yeah sure but I need that
looks it looks fun it's really fun I
just I'm hoping as long as those
controls are smooth like I'm totally
down but I mean what will happen what to
see kind of what comes out of it I
mentioned during the trailer that I hope
this is like the Duke Nukem 2014 I'm
kind of serious about this because if
you're unfamiliar with duke nukem
forever the last game the Duke was kind
of stale and it's I I'm looking at this
and I'm like this is the sort of hero
that is like absolutely like ridiculous
the drum shots like what the hell were
those so I mean it looks like a guy was
just like a badass attitude that doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything and I don't
know I have to see more I gotta get my
hands on it
like right now I'm interested so I that
does it for my reaction if you're new to
the channel you can click Subscribe read
about here do that Lulu movies it's good
and then when you're done with that you
can go check out my gaming channel right
here that's cyber channel wonderful
annotation Ryan make it yellow thanks
buddy I do a lot of let's play stuff but
I also have like a few shows like some
top five lists and a series where I kind
of like break down major gaming events
and I'm hoping soon to break down some
of your favorite games and help you
understand the more etc etcetera will
see you kind of what that show becomes
but uh please check it out i was told
that i can shout out to anybody good
night
I'm kidding first I just want to throw a
shout out to Lauren God who was right
here sitting where approximately where I
was the first time was on the show I
just want to thank you so much for
introducing me to Ryan and obviously all
of this which is turned into a huge
thing and also thank you to a lot of you
that have come and checked out my
channel uh it's been incredible two
weeks for me or whatever this video
comes out power was just like sudden
growth and like honestly from the bottom
my heart you guys the real reject fans
you guys are [ __ ] awesome so keep up
the good work and till next time cyber
it out that's my that's how I ended Ryan
that's how I ended that's how I do it
Pat it there